I've been ready for this moment please I
understand I'm so happy to be out now
like it was it was so stressful at
points in the house I mean and then
after a lot of people start leaving the
anistar I've been feeling like the days
were longer than ever I'm just glad to
be breathing fresh air hello and you
made it to finale night all the way and
you helped get Tamar a big ol check this
was life-changing for the both of us
glad one of us paid it I am so happy
that we had the opportunity to mend our
relationships for too long we have just
been a roller coaster of emotions
between the two of us a lot of people
didn't know that and I'm just glad we
were able to fix it
in the house and we probably would have
never fixed it if we weren't stuck in
the house together so I was happy to see
her win I feel like we never got a clear
explanation of what was the beef what
was that the core of the beef between
the two of you it was too many things to
even try to mention like you know we've
known each other for 20 years so it was
like multiple things have happened
something loved her like she blamed me
for it and it wouldn't even my fault you
know to me but it's overall it was just
like a whole bunch of stuff like we just
came off a tour together it was things
they have an unsorted would think about
having two there in our pan it was a lot
there was a lot for my perspective you
know what sometimes we have to go back
and revisit the past and kind of hash it
out so you can get a clearer
understanding as to oh I'm so sorry I
don't know that hurts you and apologize
and move on and that's how we got
through it both really wanted to now a
lot happened in the real world while you
were inside this house one Ariana Grande
drops of a song that you have a writing
credit on
stay hey then if you want to but I only
hate on it cuz I want to I still feel
like a winner because if you could come
out the house and have a number one
record on the radio thank you thank you
to the writers who basically state
sample of songs I wrote for NSYNC years
ago it makes me I want you it made me a
writer on the new ariana grande song and
his number one amp then also Andy Cohen
became a dad he was born about a week
ago and Jimin know he told me that he
was having a son what am I talking about
he [ __ ] with a full head of hair hey
you so cute my phone right but you did
awesome miss the most epic baby shower
of all time out if out in wild weather
day
[Applause]
that's dope
Wow was there I'll hold a mouse lives
all of it all of them I'm gonna sue Andy
I love you can't wait to see the baby
all right what was harder big brother or
housewives that's a hard word um depends
on which season of houseless you're
talking about it we've had some tough
ones um but this was hard because I
never got a chance to talk to my family
like being in a house stuck in here for
like a full month I just started going
crazy in a moment I was like okay like I
really need to see my family and you
start feeling alone and you get paranoid
cause you think everybody's against you
yeah I like to at least be able to talk
to my family are you ready to re-enter
housewives world I feel like you have to
film the reunion kind of soon um we do
we supposed to do it on March 7 but the
crazy thing is I haven't seen the show
in over a month so I don't know if
people hate me now because of the show I
don't know if things are good or bad for
me on Housewives so i'ma have to catch
on it catch up on that - it's all good
we've just wrapped the Tokyo trip is
where the season is right now okay so
I'm not looking pretty positive right
now looking good oh thank God thank is
you know in the beginning this season
some of y'all were mad at me it uh but
it's okay